ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman okay today i want to start with
something a little different we're going
to really do a deep dive
into the architecture and the genesis of
right-wing propaganda and how an idea
will be put forward with no evidence and
then the fact
that an opinion show has put it forward
then becomes the basis for more
reporting and more commentary we've
talked about this cycle before
we're also going to look at how this one
in particular
includes a complete reversal of the
burden of proof where there will be an
assertion made by a right-wing
propagandist in this case tucker carlson
and then before you know it his position
becomes
okay well if you don't believe what i'm
putting forward without evidence
prove that i am wrong which is not how
burden of proof works okay so let's jump
right into it
this is uh the sequence of the
positioning that fbi agents
were involved in coordinated and
participated in the january 6 trump
riots so we
start with the tucker carlson segment
from last week
where he puts this forward let's take a
look but strangely some of the key
people who participated
on january 6th have not been charged
look at the documents the government
calls those people unindicted
co-conspirators
what does that mean well it means that
in potentially every single case they
were fbi operatives
okay so the languages it means
potentially that they were all fbi
officers there's no actual evidence of
that
and there's also all sorts of other
reasons we went over last week why
someone might not be named in an
indictment
and it could relate to the sequence in
which cases are being put together
it could relate to uh protecting
someone's identity uh for
uh fears of their safety the the point
is tucker says it's possible they're all
fbi agents but he's provided no evidence
that that's the case
really in the capital on january 6th
for example one of those unindicted
co-conspirators is someone government
documents identify only as person two
according to those documents person two
stayed in the same hotel room as a man
called thomas caldwell an
insurrectionist
so again no evidence that person two is
an fbi
agent a man alleged to be a member of
the group the oath keepers
person two also quote stormed the
barricades at the capitol on january 6th
alongside thomas caldwell
so understand that first tucker says
without evidence person two may be an
fbi agent
and then he says person two stormed the
capital therefore fbi agents stormed the
capital but you've not proved the first
part
the government's indictments further
indicate that caldwell who by the way is
a 65 year old man
yes dangerous insurrectionist was led to
believe there would be a quote quick
reaction force also participating on
january 6th
that quick reaction force caldwell was
told would be led by someone called
person three who had a hotel room and an
accomplice with them
but wait here's the interesting thing
person two
and person three were organizers of the
riot
so again without evidence he says
persons two and three could be fbi
agents
and they stormed the capital and were
organizers therefore the fbi organized
the thing
the government knows who they are but
the government has not
charged them why is that
you know why they were almost certainly
working for the fbi
and then look at the language almost
certainly but he's presented no evidence
there's no
evidence
so fbi operatives were organizing
the attack on the capital no evidence on
january 6
according to government documents that's
not what the government documents say
that's an interesting transition the
documents just say persons two and three
were organizers
he now says well the documents say that
they were fbi agents the documents don't
say that
and those two are not alone in all
revolver news reported there are quote
upwards of 20 unindicted co-conspirators
in the oath keeper indictments
okay so now that is the baseline this
was the first crazy story last week
where we said
where is tucker coming up with this
stuff he's not citing any evidence
he mentions revolver news
so the next day now that this is
starting to get attention
he brings on the guy who wrote the story
for revolver news
and pay attention to what that guy says
now
daryn beatty heads up revolver news
we're glad to see him tonight darren
thanks so much
for coming on it sounds like according
to this
i have to say remarkable piece that
you've just put up late last night
read it in bed at midnight that the fbi
was organizing the riots of january 6th
well yes it certainly suggests that
possibility and i'm hearing from
okay you guys heard that right it's
tucker brings on the guy who's his
source
where did tucker get the idea that fbi
agents organized
uh the trump riots and storm the capital
well he says he got it from this article
he brings on the guy who wrote it and he
says well it
certainly suggests that that is a
possibility
that is not evidence that this is the
case
people that this is the most important
and the darkest
investigative piece they've seen in
years that's
another meaningless statement he's
hearing from people
that this is a very dark piece so
day one is tucker putting forward this
idea
fbi agents stormed the capital revolver
wrote about it
he brings on the source from revolver
and all that the revolver source can say
is
it certainly suggests that that is
a possibility we have still seen no
evidence but
now it's in in the ecosystem it's now a
runaway train
it's an endless feedback loop signal
boost
so the next day i mean listen tucker
reported on it i think it was tuesday
and then the revolver news guy went on
and said oh yeah yeah it certainly
suggests it's a possibility on wednesday
so then on thursday now we have
congressman louis gomer on the floor of
the house saying
we've got to investigate the fbi's
involvement in this entire thing take a
look at this
you know
so if there were federal agents that
were involved
on january 6 for which we have no
evidence
we really need to know
what the fbi knew and when they knew it
and not only that
we need to know how much participation
did any of our
federal friends either at doj
fbi or any of the intel community
what kind of role were they playing now
what's very so now the train has left
the station you can't it's a runaway
train
but what's interesting is that we've
been saying
since january 7th hey you know what
there's a disproportionately high number
of
off-duty law enforcement that were
involved in this
there is an over-representation of
current and former members of the
military that we need to look at
these right-wingers don't want to look
at that they never wanted to look at
that
but now that they can without evidence
get on this tucker idea of it was the
fbi
tucker brings on a source the source
says well i don't know maybe it is
possible
now all of a sudden they're demanding
investigations and it's all based on
nothing this is how they signal boost
each other tucker does an opinion piece
and then it gets to the house of the
floor of the house in under 48 hours
tuesday night to thursday morning here's
another example this is the sheriff
sheriff clark uh i mean you know who
really cares what he says but again the
point here is
it very quickly becomes the the baseline
for the commentaries they need an
outside
commission you cannot have the senate
judiciary do this they don't know how
and they're afraid
of what the fbi might have on them that
they they might leak
so you need an outside commission a
panel
my suggestion for example would be that
this should be headed by ellen thurston
okay i mean it's laughable that alan
dershowitz is going to run this panel
but
they were just voting against a
commission to investigate what happened
on january 6th
and we have lots of evidence and lots of
reason to think that that should be
investigated but now
without evidence the fbi did it says
tucker and he's got no sources that
actually say anything definitive
now they want a panel and they want alan
dershowitz heading it up so this is how
it works
it's all signal boosted on nothing it's
built on nothing
and then as it continued tucker carlson
eventually pulls a bait and switch
tucker knows he can't actually prove
any of this because there's no evidence
for it he then flips it around and says
well prove us wrong if we're wrong
prove us wrong tucker that's not how
burden of proof works but he doesn't
care
here we go they became hysterical when
we mentioned it
you can't say that they screamed that's
not allowed
the geniuses at twitter weighed in to
inform us that the people we had
described as agents of the fbi were in
fact
just fbi informants so shut up okay now
if that's
even true that's a completely different
thing
uh the fbi regularly has all sorts of
bad people working as
informants with the promise or
suggestion that maybe you'll get less of
a sentence or maybe whatever
but if that's even true those are not
fbi agents and to suggest that
makes absolutely no sense if that's even
true hilarious
but we won't shut up and we shouldn't it
could not be more obvious at this point
that the government is in fact hiding
something probably quite a few things
so best to abandon theatrics and find
out what they are hiding
that's our job to many in corporate
media who claim that we are spreading
russian disinformation
instead please calmly answer these three
questions
first how many of the so-called
insurrectionists on january 6
had a relationship with the fbi how many
of these fbi moles encouraged
others that day to break the law at the
capitol
we haven't heard anyone answer these
questions or even address them
if the answer is none if none of the
protesters were secretly working with
the fbi that day
then we were wrong so we know that there
was
at least one fbi informant that was
there
but that doesn't prove tucker's case
that tells us
these were bad enough people who were on
the radar of the fbi
that at least one was functioning as an
informant it does nothing to prove
tucker's case and now he shifts the
burden of proof
and we will apologize for it sincerely
we'll admit it immediately
but if the answer is not none and we're
pretty sure it
isn't none then people who claim
otherwise
are liars and hacks and should leave the
public stage immediately because they
have
betrayed their readers and viewers right
two if the justice department knew there
were going to be protesters massing at
the capitol that day and it's clear they
did know
then why didn't they do anything to stop
the riot why did police at the capitol
allow protesters to walk in as video
shows that they did
now that's very deceptive there are
moments when police recognizing they
simply don't have the numbers to hold
back protesters
moved barriers common crowd control uh
it's been
discussed ad nauseam here the reason
that additional forces and troops and
police and officers were slow to get
there
was that donald trump took hours to
actually make it happen he had to be
begged
in order to do it and tucker's not
telling you that because it doesn't help
his narrative
that doesn't make sense no it does
what's going on here why is no one
asking that question
we are third and finally why can't we
see the tape for ourselves
the government is hiding more than 14
000 hours of video surveillance tape
that shows exactly what did happen at
the capitol that day
why are they hiding that and why aren't
news organizations demanding to see it
you'd hate to think that nbc news for
example or
vox or the atlantic or the washington
post or the daily beast or the new york
times or
any of them so this is also a red
herring i mean we have
tens of thousands of hours of what
happened i don't know how many
more hours we need to watch but we have
endless hours
and we we watched it live are in fact
working to protect the regime
at the expense of the public but
unfortunately we are starting to
conclude that
please prove us wrong and there it is
please prove us wrong and of course
when you present a case completely
without any evidence and then tell
others to prove you wrong
you are now completely uh in the
paradigm of the conspiracy theorist
this is similar to the lab leak stuff
prove it wasn't
uh a lab leak and until then that's what
we believe it was well hold on
do you have any evidence to actually
suggest that and so this is a
classic bait and switch he presents the
case without evidence
he brings his source on who can only say
it suggests the possibility that this
was the case
louis gohmert and everybody else donald
jr and everybody talks about it
and then when pushed up against the wall
all tucker can say is
prove me wrong prove a negative which is
inherently difficult to do
this is how it works and you've got to
be uh armed
uh to you have to be equipped with the
tools
necessary to disarm it and to understand
it
is this useful in understanding how this
stuff develops let me know you can find
me on twitter
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back
ground news is one of the first things i
would use
to get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side
of the political spectrum may not have
covered ground news can help you
build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with
or ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground news app today
by going to ground dot news slash
pacman remember that the david pakman
show is made possible by none
other than you through the david pakman
show membership program
you can sign up at joinpackman.com a
deep discussion uh coming on today's
bonus show which is just for our members
uh about joe manchin and this voting
rights act stuff and i i'm
i'm getting increasingly uh
frustrated maybe is the word with what's
going on with this guy
uh but but we predicted it we predicted
it that story and many others on today's
bonus show you can get instant access by
signing up at joinpakman.com
let's talk a little bit about the
pandemic we are embroiled right now
in a battle between coronavirus vaccines
and something known as the delta coveted
variant we're also going to talk more
about the delta variant
on today's bonus show we have an
extraordinarily strong situation here in
the united states against the virus as i
will show you
shortly but there are real warning signs
globally right now which signal that
unless we keep vaccinating and really
vaccinate more people more quickly
we could be in a real problematic
situation
very soon within a couple of months so
let me walk you through it at first
glance
if you look at u.s coveted cases you see
that cases have dropped now more than 95
percent
from the pandemic high of about 255 000
cases a day
now down to about 11 000 cases a day
that is a massive reduction
more than 95 when you look at covet
deaths in the united states
you also see really strong numbers in
fact
deaths are down more than 91 from their
pandemic high
of more than 3 400 per day to just
300 deaths per day now these are
fantastic numbers we are getting down to
what we would call like baseline
flu level risk now when you look
globally
it still looks good but it's not quite
as good and what i mean by that is that
while globally cases are still down
they're decreasing more and more slowly
global cases peaked around 830 000 we're
now down
about 56 percent to about 470
000 global coveted cases per day
but if you're looking at the charts that
we're displaying here you'll see the
decline is leveling out it's a decline
but it's a slower and slower decline and
similarly on global deaths
we see deaths are now down globally
about 44
from their peak but just in the last few
days that decline
has also started to slow down a little
bit so what's happening here what's
driving this
what's happening is that a more
contagious by about 60 percent variant
called the delta variant is spreading
quickly in some countries
this variant as we talked about last
week with dr rasheesh jah
this is a variant that not only spreads
60 more quickly
it's becoming dominant if we look at
cases in the united kingdom
cases are going up now this is not
cases are going down but more slowly we
are actually seeing an increase in cases
in the united kingdom they were down to
under 2 000 new cases a day
they're now back up to almost 10 000
cases a day now you might see this and
say david this is no problem you know
why
because in the us we've vaccinated way
more people than in the united kingdom
so we don't have to worry and you would
be
100 percent wrong if you look at
vaccination rates by country
you see that the u.s has fully
vaccinated 45 percent of our population
and the uk has fully vaccinated more 47
of its population it is wrong to say we
don't have to worry about
delta because we vaccinated more people
we haven't
what's happening is that the delta
variant
is dominant in the uk already and in the
u.s it is not yet
dominant this variant started in india
60 of new cases in the uk are now the
delta variant
only 10 of new cases in the us are now
the delta variant
so what that means is we are simply
on a delay from what is happening in the
united kingdom now let's be really
really clear
if you were vaccinated at least with the
vaccines approved here
here pfizer moderna or johnson and
johnson
you are protected against the delta
variant the vaccines work
really well against the delta variant
the problem
is that 55 of the country has no
protection right now
and so when you say well our pool of
vaccinated people
is half the country and this variant
spreads 60 percent more easily
you are going to get more and more cases
among the unvaccinated
but you will also get more cases among
the vaccinated because
vaccination is not 100 it's just simple
math
if you have a vaccine that's 95
effective
when there aren't many cases around you
that five percent that's not protected
is less likely to get the virus
if you have a 95 effective vaccine and
there's a ton of cases around you
because of unvaccinated people
it's just statistically more likely you
will have an interaction
with an unvaccinated and possibly
infected person and you'll see more of
what are called
breakthrough cases never mind of course
that among the unvaccinated if something
is 60 percent more contagious
it's going to spread like wildfire among
the unvaccinated so this is now a race
if we can keep vaccinating maybe we can
suppress the delta variant better than
the uk
simply because we're behind where they
are
in terms of the spread of that variant
becoming dominant it's
uh you could say a geographical thing it
got to the uk first
60 of their new cases are now delta only
10 of ours are
it's still here it's still spreading the
percentage of cases here that are delta
is growing but we have the benefit of
you know it seems like it's probably a
couple of months of time
to get more and more people vaccinated
that's the fundamental battle right now
i'd get vaccinated i did uh and if i
were you
i would do the exact same thing let's
now talk a little bit about the
evolution
of vaccine opposition globally
most people in my audience probably
agree
that the united states is special but
you might disagree
in the ways in which the united states
is special
but the u.s is right up there with
russia
as one of the only two major countries
in the world in terms of opposition to
the covid vaccine this is data from a
morning consult poll
of more than 75 000 weekly interviews
on the topic of the covid vaccine and it
looked at vaccine opposition
and it also looked at reasons for
vaccine opposition
in the united states 20 of the
population is unwilling to get
vaccinated we knew that number from
before
that number seems to be holding steady
one in five americans
says they will not be getting vaccinated
in russia
and only in russia is that number higher
among the countries surveyed
where 37 of russians
say no vaccine now behind the united
states are australia and france with 17
vaccine opposition germany at 16 percent
south korea at 12 if you look at you
know japan and uk
only nine and eight percent respectively
are unwilling to get vaccinated now
there's something important to consider
here
in the u.s twenty percent plan
not to get vaccinated when we have the
top vaccines in the world
fully available the testing in the
russian
sputnik vaccine actually has been sort
of murky
and so while russian opposition is
higher
in some sense it makes sense because of
the sketchy
propaganda and nebulous testing data
around that vaccine russia promoted
their vaccine as
the world's first coveted vaccine making
sort of a show of the speed with which
they put it out
uh they've also pushed some ineffective
coveted treatments like arbidal
and gripharon and cage's cell so there
actually might be more empirical reason
to be skeptical in russia
and if you look at the reasons why
people are unwilling to get vaccinated
in different countries you'll see that
in russia
43 percent of the vaccine opposed say
they're worried about side effects
and 25 percent are worried that trials
move too quickly
it actually does seem that they did uh
in the u.s
the reason for oppositions are 34 side
effects
and 32 trials move too fast which is a
republican talking point here that is
not based in reality trials moved
at exactly the speed that they were
supposed to the phase 3 trials
were completed there's a question as to
whether that was the case in russia
and then the rest of the vaccine
opposition in the u.s
is based on either you don't think the
vaccine will work
you don't trust the companies that are
making the vaccines you believe you
don't need the vaccine because
your risk of getting covered is very low
so the us
an exceptional country standing out as
one of the top two
anti-vaxx countries along with russia
i believe that the us is special and
it's special in the amount of
conspiratorial thinking that people fall
for
and often with really complicated
explanations for stuff
that are far more complicated than the
real explanation
and it's a culmination of decades of
terrible education for much of the
country terrible news sources
that these people count on which push
this stuff
not understanding science which again
sort of links back to education in many
cases
and a republican party that has adopted
most of the worst
instincts about every issue and a
polarization
that seems to make everything even a
virus masks vaccines
everything becomes political this is the
culmination of that
uh globally high vaccine opposition when
the vaccine is the solution
the vaccine is the solution to the delta
variant the vaccine is the solution to
the pandemic
now the good news is still 80
of the country will get vaccinated or at
least probably will there's an 11
slice that says they're unsure right now
but only 20 percent like only is
definitely opposed to the vaccine if we
were to get to 80
vaccination we would absolutely crush
this virus delta variant and all
so if we want to find something positive
here
uh that is exactly what it would be
we'll have more coverage of this
on our instagram page so make sure
you're following us there
at david pakman show and make sure
you're following me on instagram as well
at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
so there's an insane new report about
another one of the near
complete disasters of the trump
administration's handling early in the
covid19 pandemic and the news is that
donald trump floated the idea of sending
foreigners
who were in the united states and
infected with covet 19
to guantanamo bay detention center in
cuba
the very same guantanamo bay detention
center
where um we keep and
interrogate with enhanced techniques
which some call
torture those suspected of being
terrorists they aren't always and that's
a whole other
issue and question mark but this is just
unbelievable and i'm actually unsure
which aspect of this is most disturbing
but i'll get to that
a forbes reports that former president
donald trump early on
in the covet 19 pandemic floated the
idea of sending infected american
tourists to the guantanamo bay
naval base in cuba according to an
excerpt
of an upcoming book which adds new
detail to the behind the scenes chaos
of the trump administration's
controversial pandemic response
explaining that nightmare scenario
inside the trump administration's
response to the pandemic that changed
history
the book details a february 2020 meeting
where trump
shocked aides with the suggestion as
white house officials debate i mean this
is like
it's like satire as white house
officials debated how to handle
americans infected with the virus abroad
trump reportedly asked staff members
assembled in the situation room
whether americans could be quarantined
on the caribbean base
where the u.s also holds terrorism
suspects
in the infamous guantanamo bay prison
don't we have an
island we own the president reportedly
asked eager to keep the u.s numbers low
what about guantanamo
the excerpt says aides were stunned but
trump still brought up the idea a second
time before it was quashed by
staff members citing the poor optics of
housing americans near the prison now
when this was initially reported it
seemed as though by american tourists
trump meant foreigners this seems to
mean
americans who went abroad and came back
with the virus
americans which it's insane either way
but it's sort of like
an additional layer of insanity
uh the book which is based on interviews
with roughly 180 people including senior
white house staffers and government
health leaders
is set to be published june 29th
uh representatives for trump did not
immediately respond to forbes requests
for comment
um trump reportedly said we import goods
we are not going to import a virus also
reported in addition to the exchange
about gitmo
the washington post published excerpt of
the book recounts some of trump's
complaints about testing
testing is killing me he reportedly
claimed in a march phone call to then
hhs secretary
alex azar complaining i'm going to lose
the election
because of testing that's been widely
reported that trump
said we've got a slow testing down it's
sort of like if you've got to stop
pregnancy just stop testing for it
uh even though that doesn't really stop
a woman from being pregnant if you don't
get a pregnancy test
nine months later they're still a baby
um trump's idea was just don't test for
kovid so
i'm actually unsure what is the craziest
aspect of this
like there's the xenophobic aspect if
you interpret this to mean
foreigners who come to the us and have
covid
but when you actually look into it more
deeply it seems trump meant
americans who came back from vacations
with kovid
number two is the legal aspect the most
concerning like
is there any legal framework for taking
someone with a virus not suspected of
any crime
even when someone is suspected of a
crime we can debate whether they should
be sent to gitmo um
you know foreign enemy combatants and
that legal infrastructure
a legal uh american citizen
or permanent resident who just has a
virus there's the legal question about
sending them to guantanamo bay
but for me the most concerning aspect of
this
is how idiotic is it to think
that sending people with the virus
to gitmo would otherwise prevent the
pandemic in the u.s where you can say
we will just go forward normally we
don't have to do anything differently
which was trump's approach during those
early months
other than sending americans who come
back with the virus to guantanamo bay
for me that's the craziest part the
legal questions of course the moral
ethical questions absolutely
the xenophobic aspect to this if you
interpret it to mean foreigners
those are all crazy things but the
really wild part
is it again goes to the idea of trump's
fundamental misunderstanding of
we don't need to do anything other than
send people to gitmo if they come back
from their vacation with the virus
as if that would have prevented the pr
the pandemic
we know that trump was totally misguided
on all aspects of this
and ultimately we know how that turned
out um
guys remember how after the 2020
election
donald trump never really admitted
that he lost and he never really
conceded
but he eventually started saying things
like
the next administration and we were kind
of like that's
kind of a concession and he said to sean
hannity last week
we didn't win and we said oh
it's kind of trump admitting that he
didn't win trump has now resurfaced
in a completely laughable embarrassing
and pathetic excuse for an interview on
a program called
just the news on a channel i guess
called
real america's voice i i don't know what
any of this stuff is
to tell the interviewer david brody that
trump never admitted defeat
and that trump still has not conceded
the 2020 election
it has to be seen to be believed
and that is exactly what we are going to
do here is the first clip listen to this
insanity
i want to start with something you told
sean hannity uh last week the headlines
were about how
you admitted defeat in the 2020 election
when you said we didn't win
is that an accurate headline did you
admit defeat i just want to understand
that
no i never admitted defeat by the way
how bad does he sound
no i never admitted defeat of a
lot of things happening right now i
think that that was an election that was
i don't think all you have to do is read
the newspapers and
see what's coming out now no i've never
the word is concede i have not conceived
so there is trump saying
i have not conceded and i have not
admitted defeat now
remember conceding defeat is not legally
relevant and it's not legally binding in
any way
this is how trump strings along his
ignorant followers oh wow
did you that was a signal trump didn't
technically
admit defeat something's coming he
hasn't conceded
conceding is legally irrelevant it's
electorally irrelevant it's a formality
that normal adult politicians
engage in when they've lost but it is
legally meaningless and trump is also
straight up lying
he said to hannity we didn't win he
wildly said we'll see what happens with
that
alluding to this return to office in
august but this is just last week
remember this guys
you ever considered it and are you
considering it
well i am and frankly if you think of it
that's what i've been doing and talking
about
for a long time and i guess that's why
we got him by surprise in 16
and in 20 we did much better than we did
in 16 and
[Music]
shockingly we were supposed to win
easily at 64 million votes and we got 75
million votes and
we didn't win but we didn't win the
whole thing
but we'll see what happens on that trump
said it
now he denies saying it he lies all the
time
uh period and um he now plays
coy with the term concession and it's
all just
a joke this entire interview was bonkers
uh trump continues to blame mike pence
for accepting the 2020 election results
as if he had a choice right he's still
disappointed in pence
i don't want to listen to the new york
times they always like to write about
the relationship between you and mike
pence
can you explain that to us right now
there's a portion of the mag a crowd you
know the deal they're never going to
forgive
the vice president for not kicking uh
those certain disputed election results
back to uh state legislatures what's
your what's your take on mike pence and
and and how what's the relationship like
well i've always liked mike and i'm very
disappointed that he didn't send it back
to the legislatures when you have more
votes than you have voters in some cases
now that's not true
you didn't have more votes than voters
and again disappointed pence couldn't do
anything
pence couldn't do anything and trump's
own followers don't know that they now
heckle pence as traitor
and uh unpatriotic and whatever else
when you have the kind of things that
are
that were known in many cases they were
known then but
they're certainly getting better and
better known now
i was disappointed that he didn't send
it back i felt he had the right to send
it back
and he should have sent it back he is
completely wrong
pence had no ability to do anything he
could have tried some stuff that would
have been historically humiliating
he really couldn't do anything but it
doesn't matter in the world of trump
that's my opinion and i think if he did
i think those legislate
look at pennsylvania now look at look at
georgia and look at
arizona and look at others they're all
now looking at what happened during that
election
nothing will come of it trump continues
to string his followers along
nothing will come of these fake audits i
think you would have found that
uh you might very well have a different
president right now
you would not you would not what you
would have would be
an even more humiliated former
vice president and former president
pence and trump that's what you would
have but
pence couldn't do anything about it
trump also asked about 2024 his comments
they're
sort of interesting on 2024 by the way
here's my take and i'm curious to get
your take would it be accurate to say
that if a super majority of the
candidates that you're supporting right
now
if they win in in the midterms and
republicans take back the house and the
senate
uh that would make it more likely that
you would run at that point is that true
what do you think no i don't think so
but i think that's what is going to
happen
now this is super interesting trump is
asked
are you more likely to run if the people
you support in 22
do well and trump says no it's the wrong
question
and the right question shouldn't even be
asked of trump because he'll just lie
the right question is
are you more likely to win if the people
you support in 22 do well and that's
ultimately what this
hinges on and hangs on and that's what
we've been talking about
trump needs to successfully have his
coalition uh the cow thorns and the
boberts and the marjory taylor greens
they need to do well in 2022
to bolster trump for 24. i think trump
may well
run regardless of whether he does well
in 22
but his chances will be greatly
diminished if the people he supports
don't win
in the midterm election let's continue
my endorsements have meant a lot
we're almost undefeated very close to
undefeated
understand that with trump at the helm
of the republican ship
they lost the house in 2018 they lost
the senate in 2020
and they lost the white house in 2020.
trump undefeated that's
wrong in a literal sense but the spirit
of what he's saying he's been in a sense
a disaster for the republican party
they've lost everything
hundreds and hundreds of endorsements uh
people win
the republican party chair in north
carolina
and in uh georgia and you know a lot of
these are meaningless endorsements where
there's like really not anybody running
or
there's one real candidate and it's an
often an incumbent
and to say that trump's endorsement has
any value there
that's really a stretch places we just
had congressional candidates but i mean
hundreds of endorsements
and our record is i think unmatched
anywhere at any time
so i'm looking to gain the majority
first and i think it would be
i think it's very important that we do
that i don't know that would have any
impact on my decision however
that may be true it may not impact
trump's decision
but it definitely impacts his viability
just a little bit more of this have that
impact on your decision
what's going through your mind on that a
lot of people want to know
well i think i'm just looking at what's
going on i'm very unhappy with what's
going on i look at the border where
people are coming in by the millions
it's going to be by the minions very
soon
so notice that how he slips that in
they're coming in by the millions he
knows that that's not really true
so he says soon it's going to be my by
the millions and of course it's not
it already is uh oh and i look at
other things how our country is really
it's america last i was america first
i look at it and i see what's happening
and i'm not happy about it so just
meaningless drivel as i've told you
before the standing and reputation of
the united states around the world
was greatly diminished under donald
trump uh it's been greatly bolstered
early in joe biden's presidency doesn't
mean biden's perfect doesn't mean biden
is even great on policy it's just the
reputation of the united states around
the world so
just about every aspect of this
completely backwards during the
interview but the key point there trump
again playing coy i didn't concede i
didn't concede
when the reality is the concession is
unnecessary and it's just another way to
continue
stringing along his low information
voters into saying well maybe he will
come back because technically he didn't
concede
much more of this stuff is to be
expected as we get closer and closer to
the 2022 midterms and trump needs to put
some wins up on the board
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out
at patreon.com david pakman show
there is a super interesting article in
the new york times about tucker carlson
and journalists and anonymous sources
that i want to look at with you today
and what's most interesting there's a
few things that are interesting about
this article one
are the things we learn about tucker
carlson specifically
but also what we learn about this
relationship in terms of trading
for access that exists in general in
politics but also in the political media
space so let's jump right into it the
article in the new york times called
tucker carlson calls journalists animals
he's
also their best source and the article
by ben
smith uh starts last month i texted
tucker carlson to ask him a question
that was on my mind
did you get vaccinated when was the last
time you had sex with your wife
and in what position he replied we can
trade intimate details
then we argued back and forth about
vaccines and he ended the conversation
with a friendly invitation to return to
his show
always a good time one question you may
be asking if you're a new york times
reader is
why are you exchanging texts with tucker
carlson the fox news host who recently
described the media at large
as cringing animals who are not worthy
of respect and if you're a tucker
carlson viewer you may also be asking
how can the guy who tells you every
night that the media
is lying be texting with the enemy
the answer is one of washington's open
secrets
mr carlson a proud traitor to the elite
political class
spends his time when he's not denouncing
the liberal media
trading gossip with them he's the go-to
guy for sometimes unflattering stories
about donald j
trump and for coverage of the internal
politics of fox news
not to mention stories about carlson
himself i won't talk here about any
off-the-record conversations i may have
had with him
but 16 other journalists none from the
times
told me on background that he has been
as three of them put it
a great source in trump's washington
tucker carlson is a primary super secret
source the media writer and trump
chronicler michael wolff writes in his
forthcoming collection of essays
he explained i know this because i know
what he has told me
and i can track his exquisite too good
not to be true gossip
through unsourced reports and as it
often emerges into the accepted wisdom
so takeaway number one is
we knew it but this is confirmation
tucker carlson plays a character on his
program
um in the midst of all the anti-vaccine
stuff he's almost certainly been
vaccinated as has his family i'm sure
um in the midst of all of his attacks on
the media
and his sort of cow towing to this
populist stuff that he does
uh he is a sort of regular
uh elite insider that communicates with
all these very same people
shouldn't surprise us we already
suspected that article goes on to say mr
carlson was particularly well positioned
to be a source about the trump
administration
his fox platform where in may he had a
nightly average of three million viewers
made him someone who mattered to trump a
close follower of television ratings he
has a former reporter's eye for detail
and anecdote and his observations can be
detected
in the lurid tales of trump's chaotic
court
and fox's own tumultuous internal
politics
a coming book by the reporter michael
bender
includes a moment in which carlson sends
trump's calls to voicemail
after the first presidential debate last
fall when he was criticized for
repeatedly interrupting joe biden
when trump finally reaches carlson the
book describes verbatim
an exchange between the two men that
cast mr carlson in a flattering light
everyone says i did a good job trump
tells carlson i don't know who told you
that was good mr carlson says
it was not good mr bender declined to
comment on the sourcing
that allowed him to so precisely
reconstruct a conversation between the
two men of course
the belief would be well the source is
tucker himself
the article continues brian stelter the
host of the cnn show reliable sources
told me quote you can see tucker's
fingerprints all over the hardcover
edition of his 2020
book hoax which excoriates fox for
amplifying trump's falsehoods
he said he couldn't stomach talking to
carlson who has grown ever more hard
line
for the updated paperback version that
was just released
carlson was born to a world of insiders
and story shapers and makes no secret of
it
his father was a reporter in l.a in san
diego before reagan appointed him
director of voice of america
and the son grew up with a generation of
elite washington journalists
in 2018 tucker said i've always lived
around people who were wielding
authority around
the ruling class um a former new york
observer
media writer sridhar papu recalled to me
that when he first traveled to
washington to cover the white house
correspondents association dinner in the
2000s it was carlson who asked him
do you have an invitation to tammy's
referring to the annual brunch for media
insiders
co-hosted by tammy haddad the
well-connected
former msnbc producer so here you start
to get the sense
that not only is tucker not the guy
waging war on the so-called elite media
he's actually a guy trading on his
membership in that very group
in his private life surprising not at
all
not at all couple other interesting
things here carlson said he turned
against his fellow elites after the 2008
financial crisis
his political shift also transformed his
long journeyman's career as a writer
magazine writer and msnbc conservative
and make him fox's leading tribune
of the pro-trump masses but his decades
of washington relationships have
produced a tiresome conversation among
carlson's old friends
about what he really stands for whether
he's really a racist or whether he
cynically plays one on tv who knows and
what does it matter anyway
that's the same analysis of trump when
we've said
oh it sort of seems like trump plays coy
with anti-semitic stuff but his daughter
converted to judaism his grandkids are
jewish his son-in-law etc etc
what you have to remember is that it
doesn't actually matter in the end
if trump uh placates and coalesces that
very group
it doesn't really matter what's in his
head and that is amplified
with tucker carlson as well and the
article points out as we have
carlson's recent fixations include
suggesting the january 6th capital
insurrection was
a provocation staged by the fbi and that
making children wear masks
is abuse do we know whether that is
really tucker's view or not no we don't
i suspect it's not
uh but that is uh something that will
remain a question so the takeaways are
tucker's just like all of these other
people there's really no difference he
is the very same type of elite that he
decries
and unfortunately and i don't want to
make this a bigger thing about populism
and grifting in general
but there is a lot of populist rhetoric
that is rhetoric alone and it is not
actually the beliefs of the individuals
behind it and that can apply on the left
and the right
on the right a lot of the populist
rhetoric is a cover for
just a sort of like elite typical uh
dude
like tucker on the left sometimes the
populist rhetoric is cover
for an authoritarian tendency which
we've also talked about before
last thing you know you might remember
donald trump's
discussions of anonymous sources
anonymous sources shouldn't be allowed
trump even seemingly misunderstanding
that an anonymous source
isn't anonymous to the journalists it's
typically that the journalist is just
saying
i won't identify you it's very
interesting that such
a notable figure on the right is
such a prominent anonymous source when
he's supposedly part of a movement that
decries the status quo of the media
which as fomented by donald trump during
his presidency
includes the criticism of the use of
anonymous sources so
nothing massively surprising in the
article
it confirms a lot of things we suspected
uh but very interesting
in that our suspicions seem to be have
been very much
accurate uh about tucker carlson
let's talk a little bit about matt gates
republican congressman
matt gates from florida we know is being
investigated for all sorts of different
things
including potentially child sex
trafficking
we have a new report which tells us that
matt gates could be charged as soon as
july meaning as soon as next month
this is a report from abc which says
since federal prosecutors obtained the
cooperation of congressman matt gates's
once close ally in may
sources tell abc news the ongoing
investigation which includes sex
trafficking allegations involving gates
has engulfed the tight-knit central
florida political scene
as prosecutors continue their
investigation of the florida congressman
former seminole county tax collector
joel greenberg who reached a plea deal
last month has been assisting federal
agents
in the sprawling probe that has recently
revved up its focus on alleged
corruption
and fraud stemming from greenberg's time
in office and beyond
multiple sources familiar with the
matter told abc news
sources told abc news that prosecutors
believe
a decision about whether or not to bring
charges against gates
could come as early as july we
believed we were getting closer and
closer to a possible
charge ultimately it will be a decision
which may be charges it may not
that seems to be exactly the direction
that it's going
sources said the probe into the
congressman has ramped up
in recent weeks investigators have
started interviewing more women
who were allegedly introduced to gates
through greenberg who last month pled
guilty pleaded guilty
to sex trafficking a 17 year old girl
who later went on to work in porn
and introducing her to other adult men
since may a new round of target letters
and subpoenas in the wide-ranging
investigation have been sent out
abc news has learned so first of all
just what's already been reported is a
lot but
now that we are seeing that there are
multiple women that are being talked to
and we are seeing how long it's taking
to for this to go forward
they may be building an incredibly uh
significant case
against matt gates we know about uh
greenberg and we know about greenberg's
knowledge of matt gates's activity
um and i still am unconvinced by the way
that uh gates won't end up relatively
unscathed so on the one hand
feds typically charge when they have a
really strong case we saw this with a
lot of the people involved
in the trump russia probe roger stone
michael flynn etc these cases were
iron-clad by the time they actually
led to charges they maybe are being
extra cautious
because if they're going to charge a
sitting congressman
you know it's going to be highly
politicized uh but at the same time
because it is matthew gates i just
wonder whether there are really going to
be serious consequences for this guy if
he is indeed charged
last thing gates may not even be the
biggest fish here
because abc is reporting
that as the gates investigation ramps up
feds are mounting a sweeping probe into
into the central florida political scene
so this could also
be much bigger than just matt gates we
know some people
down in florida who are familiar with
gates and follow this much more closely
they have essentially taken this
approach when i talk to them which is
this is
gates is one piece of a much bigger pie
it may not
be names that are as known as gates
they'd be people that are more known in
central florida
but there is the suspicion that this
could be a much bigger
uh i don't i mean crime ring almost
sounds too conspiratorial but
this may be a bigger series of connected
uh crimes than simply gates
and greenbergs so this may be even
bigger and without a doubt we know what
their responses are going to be this is
all political this is all a witch hunt
this is just like russia rush rush on
trump it's just like
the impeachment hoax over the perfect
phone call that's the approach they're
going to take
the feds go forward when they have
really close to ironclad cases so
maybe by july we will know we have a
voicemail number and that number is 219
to david p here's a 17 year old who
called in saying his mom doesn't want
him vaccinated
what should he do take a listen hey
david um
long time listener i've been listening
for about three years now
and i'm in quite a predicament right now
i'm 17 and my mom doesn't want me to get
vaccinated
despite everyone else in my family being
vaccinated and i was just wondering how
you would go about
kind of um getting through
um the disinformation and really
kind of breaking through with um like a
family member in specific about
just you know kind of getting behind
public safety i guess so here's the
thing it depends on whether your goal is
to convince someone or to get vaccinated
as quickly as possible
i don't know what it would take to
convince your mom to let you get the
vaccine
now the truth is that depending on what
state you're in
you don't need parental permission at
age 17 to go and get vaccinated now we
did a story on the bonus show a few
weeks ago about how the new hot thing
for teenagers
is helping each other get vaccinated
when they have anti-vaxx
parents i would never encourage anyone
to break the law but what i would say is
find out what options you have in your
state based on your age because if your
goal is just to get vaccinated
you may not need your mom's approval
depending on where you live
number two i don't know how to convince
your mom i mean this is the
you know anti-vaxx we've talked about a
lot of non-science-based beliefs
anti-vaxx is a really really stubborn
one
it can be hard to clean that one out so
to speak
and it could take months and months and
months again if the goal is to get
vaccinated
you might be 18 before you convince your
mom and then
in any state you'd be able to go and get
yourself vaccinated so i feel for you
i'm really glad to hear that even though
your mom is taking this view you seem to
have figured out what makes sense when
it comes to vaccination and public
safety that's already a great thing
you're already
you know pointing in the right direction
as you enter adulthood young adulthood
uh but really it comes down to what are
you willing to do in order to get
yourself vaccinated
the answer is a very personal one we
will go into
more detail on the bonus show today
about the delta variant which is now
predominant in the uk
and growing in the united states we will
talk about a new california plan to pay
off
all past due rent that accrued during
the coveted pandemic
very interesting decision by california
and barack obama
former president barack obama says if we
can
pass the voting rights bill
with the things joe manchin is okay with
it should be done because it's better
than nothing at the same time
if mitch mcconnell still won't go for it
does it make a difference the senate is
debating today
and we're going to talk more about this
on today's bonus show
get instant access you just sign up and
then you're in
to today's bonus show by becoming a
member at joinpackman.com we'll see you
then
or tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman